hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer Friesen TV and
I'm here with Joe Sorge he is the
director of a new documentary called
divorce Corp and also the co-author of
an accompanying book Joe thanks for
coming in thank you for having me I
appreciate it so your documentary starts
out with the notion that marriage is a
fairly simple process at least in the
legal sense but divorce is nowhere near
that simple can you talk about the
business of divorce and why it's so
complicated to get divorced you can't
simply fill out a form that says I'm
divorced you have to go to court and a
judge has to approve the divorce and you
know breaking up is traumatic on its own
never mind having to go to court and
appear before a judge and trying to
learn enough about the law if you can't
afford to pay a lawyer to do it properly
and if you can't afford to pay a lawyer
well then they often take most of your
money it's the fourth most common cause
of bankruptcy in the United States it's
not surprising that the average
contested divorce in the u.s. costs
$50,000 in the last 40 years the number
of divorce lawyers has exploded
increasing over 2,000 percent in
California alone and this is a
nationwide issue no matter what state
you live in you're going to get pulled
in talk about how family court is
different from other types of court well
family courts are called courts of
equity not courts of law and typically
an equitable matter is something that
can't be quantified in dollars and so
there's usually a non dollar solution to
an equitable issue marriage used to be a
covenant for life and if someone broke
that covenant it was difficult to come
up with a dollar amount that would
satisfy that breaking of a covenant and
so what happened is they would have a
judge come up with well what is a fair
solution to this situation where maybe
both people were working but maybe one
person was not working and the other one
was how can we come up with something
that works for both of those people and
if you have a really nice judge and a
friendly courtroom and very simple laws
that's not such a bad idea but what we
have today is 2,000 pages of family code
ridiculously complex
written half in Latin so what is the
average cost of divorce these days so
the average cost of a non contested
divorce would be between ten and twenty
thousand dollars typically and for a
contested divorce it's fifty thousand
dollars plus and you know there's some
divorces that cost twenty million
dollars he said there's two thousand
pages of this legislation regarding
divorces can you talk about when that
came to be the transition occurred
primarily in the 1970s and 1980s prior
to 1969 we had what was called the fault
divorce system you had to prove that
your spouse did something wrong like
adultery or abandonment or brutality in
order to get a divorce
in 1969 governor Ronald Reagan in
California signed the first no-fault
divorce law in the United States and
most of the other states quickly
followed where you could file for
divorce unilaterally but you just
couldn't get you couldn't finish the
process without a judge and so what
happened is that because there was this
big rush to get divorced and and frankly
primarily by women who were caught in
bad marriages prior to no-fault they
suddenly want it to go through this
process but they found that the laws had
been written to address the old
patriarchal system where the man was the
the king of the castle and so many of
the laws that pertain to the patriarchal
system no longer pertained to the
women's lib movement and women having
independence and so the legislators
under the lobbying from the national
organization of women and other groups
that advocated I think very favorable
changes to the legislation logical
and-and-and good-spirited changes of the
legislation kept writing in all these
new laws to put in these new protections
but as in many cases the law of
unintended consequences set in and so a
lot of these laws that were written in
the 60s 70s and 80s we're a good good
idea at the time no longer necessary and
create much of the confusion and
animosity that we see today in family
court on that point with alimony
payments and child support they caused a
lot of the complications so you think we
should get rid of alimony or what's your
take yeah so I personally believe
that we should eliminate alimony from
the statutes but it should be subject to
a private agreement if it's only
appropriate in less than 20% of
households today that shouldn't be
something that's done routinely as part
of a divorce it should only be done if
the couple has agreed that this is the
kind of relationship we're going to have
and therefore there should be alimony we
should look to other countries that do
things where men and women are equal or
treated equally or more equally than so
point to Scandinavia we looked at how
they handle divorce there and they do
have alimony but only for six months and
once the divorce is finalized then
there's no alimony unless they've
entered into a private agreement to
provide for alimony a big topic that you
spend a lot of time on in the
documentary is these problems with the
lawyers and these outrageous legal fees
but if people are willing to pay them I
mean that's their choice what's wrong
with that I'll tell you what's wrong
with it
I think it's an oligopoly you say well
it's a free market
lawyers can charge whatever they want to
charge however they've made the law so
complex that you pretty much have to
hire these specialty lawyers that are
divorce lawyers they're only a certain
number of them and that drives up the
their hourly rate and there it's
complicated because the judges have
special relationships with a lot of
these lawyers and unlike other public
officials judges do not have a waiting
period between public and private
practice a judge can retire one day
practice as an attorney the next day and
then go back to being a Pro Tem judge a
day later judges will oftentimes try to
get very cozy with the law firms that
they want to work for upon retirement as
a judge and so it creates a conflict of
interest the other conflicts of interest
is lawyers are allowed to contribute to
the election campaigns of judges appear
before them in court and yet give them
money toward their election campaigns
and so I'm afraid what that does is it
can allow certain law firms to buy
influence with the judge or if it's not
direct campaign contributions it could
be things like appointing the judge to
some committee that's a prestigious
committee or throwing a fundraiser for
the judge and so there's no oversight or
accountability I wouldn't say there's no
oversight there are judicial review
committees but as we point out in the
film they rarely do
appoint a judge it's extremely rare and
those review committees are made up of
judges and lawyers could you talk about
how we could get the government out of
divorce if that's even a possibility
yeah no it's a great question I think I
can I keep looking into Scandinavia to
get divorced in Scandinavia you file a
Form with the government and if you have
children then you have to wait six
months for a possible reconciliation if
there's no reconciliation then you're
divorced it seems to work there they
don't have to go to court they don't
have to ask for a judge's approval they
don't have to have lawyers reading the
2,000 page code they divide their assets
much like we have our community property
laws will divide assets in the United
States so if they went into the marriage
with separate property they walk out
with that separate property if it hasn't
been commingled but if they've invested
together if they've worked together if
they contributed to a joint account if
they bought a house together then that's
all split 50/50 right down the middle
simple split and they go to an
accountant to figure that out you don't
need a lawyer to figure that out
lawyers are not as good at math as
accountants are anyway Joe thanks again
for coming in you're welcome thanks for
having me freezin TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer's
you